let's jump to this next story let's talk
about censorship
Chris pavlovsky tweeted the French
government has demanded that Rumble
block Russian news sources like Elon
Musk I won't move our goal posts for any
foreign government Rumble will turn off
France entirely France isn't material to
us and we will challenge the legality of
this demand
uh Chris why why even turn off Rumble in
France just ignore them what can they do
you're not in France if people in France
type in rumble.com that's on the people
of France let the government of France
block the website like the Chinese
Communist Party would and then we'll
talk about it how about that
yeah
yeah
that sounds like a great idea sounds
like an awesome idea I mean government's
trying to control information right now
during war is something that they have
always done historically but I I think
it's fair to say that you know we're
reaching a level where information
Warfare is being galvanized and used
against the best interest of the general
public and if France is going to be
going after you know Russian news
sources they should be going after all
the other news sources that are also
leading to damage leading to harm if
they truly were trying to do this
equally but they're not so uh shouts out
to rumble for for standing in their
ground for allowing free speech to
thrive and and at the end of the day
people should be able to hear both sides
of the story and make up their opinions
but the thing is when you're when you're
pushing an agenda when you're fighting a
war when you want to kill somebody you
can't allow that in some instances and
that's the big bigger battle that I
think is being described here I think
it's amazing uh Elon Musk tweeted in
March that starlink had been told by
some governments to block Russian news
sources in the United States there's an
effort to try and shut down a lot of
these Russian news sources they ban
people like crazy Lee Camp he worked for
RT he had his own independent podcast
unrelated RT they banned that too
they're redacted tonight it wasn't
rejected tonight that guy they shut down
all of the shows but he had a separate
podcast that was like his own creation
and they banned that we should have him
on the show sometime I like well I've
reached out to him I don't know I've hit
him up several times cool guy but yeah
they shut him down they they shut him
down and a bunch of other people who
worked for RT started getting banned
like crazy it's just it's Chinese
Communist Party level psychotic behavior
I always liked RT during the war on
terror 2008 910 I'd be like what in the
hell actually is going on if Saddam
didn't have weapons of mass destruction
like why are we there RT was nice
because it was an outside perspective
and uh Al Jazeera because it was like
they would talk about American troop
movements and stuff that like NBC didn't
talk NBC's like we got him Osama Bin
Laden remember that guy you thought we
killed before we didn't but we got him
now and you're like oh okay okay okay
and then you know so it's good to get
outside perspectives um but like you
said they don't want you to have it dude
yeah in a time of War
I mean no I mean that was war and well
we were told the issue is the war on
terror yeah right the United States is
quickly becoming authoritarian over the
past six or so years the left is
screaming Donald Trump Donald Trump but
he's barely done anything it's like he
wouldn't even call in the the troops to
shut down the mass riding around the
country
but what they've been doing with like
sisa working with Twitter and Facebook
to censor information and shut down
speech and actively they've been Banning
news outlets I mean how do you justify
legally constitutionally the shutting
down of a news Outlet in the U.S RT
they did
I think RT chose to shut itself down
right they like they terminated
operations because they were getting
banned or something like that was that
uh Russia Today yeah it's been it's been
a minute since the story broke but I
don't look man the United States is
becoming very much a despotic regime
like the Communist Chinese party dude
they created the war on terror it's the
most generic title imagine if they
created the war on evil do you think
that they'll ever do that that we're
gonna get to a point where they'll be
like and enough people will be like
zealous and they'll be like yeah yeah
Evil's bad we gotta fight it fascism the
war on fashion the war on carbon the war
on chaos you know they're gonna be like
the war on evil
and they're gonna be like are you carbon
uh I don't know I think he's carbon get
him and they're gonna it's just so like
it's so subjective what's terrorism if
people were gonna fight for the war on
evil they would we would have seen him
step up sooner the last three years
they're preparing people for some dumb
it's just so generic like it's just it's
just a reason to Rally people into
fighting to accepting curtailing rights
and empowering military-industrial
complex to build bigger bombs more
explosive and deadly weapons uh if they
just call it I mean it wasn't even a war
it wasn't a war it was a extra military
going on isn't it I think that it's
winding down yeah I don't know but they
could use terrorism ever since the
Patriot Act in these the NDA was signed
they can use like Terror as like they're
talking about this David Pat guy they're
gonna hit him with terrorism charges or
something they want to
I don't like it man they could you hit
what do they what have they charged you
with evil like could you imagine a
reality like you're going to jail what'd
I do evil you committed to evil soon
it's coming yeah who decides if it's
Terror who decides if it's evil yeah
Whoever has the guns well that's I mean
yeah when antifa goes around for
political reasons terrorizing people
they never charge them with terrorism
and they should have yeah if they want
to play judiciously then that should
have been terrorism too but a bad
argument they might have to start
charging themselves with terrorism when
they drop bombs on schools and stuff
true but domestically antifa putting on
masks that there's a video out of I
think it's Portland OR Seattle they
they're marching through neighborhoods
they see a house that American flag so
they stop they go to his house knock on
the door and start threatening the guy
like this is Terrorism yeah okay these
people should be charged because they're
they're marching around in gangs with
with weapons and threatening people if
you want to March around in a mask with
a gun I don't I don't care at all you
want to March around with a mask and a
gun and then walk up to a house where
guys got an American flag and threaten
him you cross the line you want to walk
down the street by yourself with a pink
pullover you know collared shirt and
khakis and then knock on the door of
someone with an American flag and
threaten them you've crossed the line
right allowing people who are armed to
point guns at people in the street like
they were doing and getting away with it
without charging them for anything
that's how you know it's just it can
only get it can only get worse from here
I suppose
well they were doing it mostly
peacefully though fiery but peaceful and
that's in that remarkable who who buys
this do you see uh it was a clip from
The View that went viral where they're
like these Republicans are the ones
celebrating violence it's like are you
nuts who's like you you get like Glenn
Beck Ben Shapiro Stephen Crowder Tucker
Carlson literally when have any of the
of the key prominent right-wing
individuals ever advocated or supported
violence they've not even when it came
to George Floyd bench pair is coming up
being like this is horrible I can't
believe this happened yeah when it comes
to the antifa riots kamalaris literally
fundraises for them the bite
Administration donates to bail these
people out they Advocate to get these
people out of jail and they defend them
and say but they're peaceful protesters
fiery you had those two people who
firebombed the cop car in New York and
they get like what like 18 months or
some some ridiculously low number and
then you get people who trespass the
capital and they get four to seven years
amazing
there you go you got to be careful with
my system charging people that because
like Terror if like you're scared
because of something I did it doesn't
mean that I'm terrorizing you just
because I'm behaving a certain way
doesn't mean that I'm terrorized just
because you're feeling Terror like you
might have eaten have too much coffee
and now you're you're freaking out
because your adrenals are overloaded and
screaming like um he's a he's doing this
to be like so you want to protect
people's rights like you said you can
carry a weapon down the street and
you're okay to do that uh as long as
you're not aggressively going after
somebody
yeah well it depends where you're at in
New York City you can't even have a
pocket knife so they'll come and arrest
you that's that's the number one arrest
that they have in pocket knives yeah
yeah yeah that's that's the number I
heard that that the number one arrest in
New York City in Times Square is people
with pocket knives and police officers
just walk around trying to see who has
it and then they arrest individuals for
doing that so institutionally I should
clarify yeah again what's Happening Here
is people are trying to control the
narrative as I've been saying for a long
time and other people said it before me
the first casualty of war is the truth
and you want to of course have a
landscape right now where you're not
only just fighting in the in the real
world in Ukraine with the larger proxy
war but there's a bigger War also that's
an information War and what the French
government is trying to do here is is
One symptom of this larger war of them
trying to consolidate information
control that information so they could
use it for their own personal benefit
France is also in a very weird position
because uh you we have the Rothschild
Banker French president warning about
escalations in Ukraine saying hey we we
really got to stop it here we really
have to de-escalate the situations here
and now the French government is just
trying to ban any alternative version of
the story which of course is
predominantly done for their war that
they're trying to push as of course
France has been giving Aid to Ukraine so
so this kind of landscape is kind of
confusing and perplexing to see
especially with the larger relations and
the trade deals that just happened
between Russia and France so
um very complex point of view but there
are a lot of people that don't want you
seeing an alternative version of the
story and whether you agree with it or
not you should be able to see it for you
to judge it for yourself and I think if
we're able to do that we're able to
de-escalate a lot of the war efforts a
lot of the propaganda a lot of the
disinformation that has brought us to
the situation where a lot of people are
fearing of full all-out nuclear war this
is a real reality that we're facing
mainly because of this one kind of
mentality and denying free speech and
just pushing a war mess message non-stop
which the corporate media does all the
time you look at all the messaging on
the corporate media it's always pro-war
there's no anti-war voices anymore on
the corporate media when there was they
got extinguished Jesse Ventura had a
huge contract with MSNBC he wanted to
speak out against the wars they
literally bought him off and said you
know what we know we paid you a lot of
money just shut up and sit down don't
say anything and we're not going to
publish your show golden handcuffs they
call it exactly and they did this to
Donahue they did this to Jesse Ventura
they did this to Cheng yuger of The
Young Turks right now on MSNBC because
they weren't toting the line and pushing
the military-industrial complex
propaganda and I think the more that we
could counteract the military-industrial
complex the propaganda the
disinformation the less likely we are to
have a full all-out nuclear World War a
World War they will offer you a big
contract and it'll be for something
legitimate like you'll make you know
appearances in the show we'll have you
as a correspondent
Etc and then if you don't say what the
machine wants you to say it serves a
great benefit to have you on under
contract where you can't go say things
elsewhere so now you're getting paid mid
six figures some of these people get
millions of dollars you go on the TV you
say the war is wrong they stop booking
you you under contract you can't go
anywhere else you are effectively
careerless in limbo but well paid and
there's nothing you can do about it how
many of those contracts you think have
have rolled out over the last couple
years for just all of the information
covid stuff and everything because you
know when you see the memos like it
seems like everybody gets the same memos
and then everything everybody sort of
says the same thing online and then
there's a pattern to it you know well
that I think you know what we're
learning with the DHS colluding with
social media you know they're colluding
with with traditional media there's no
way that they have takedown requests of
Twitter and Facebook and they don't have
you know contacts at Major media Outlets
to talk with the heads about what
stories are good or bad put it this way
you think that if they're doing that
social media they're not going to the
New York Times being like hey that story
is really bad it's going to get people
killed they do that I guarantee you the
New York Times They probably go we'll
take it down we won't publish they
probably get a phone call like hey we
hear you're about to run a story about
this that's going to put us in Jeopardy
we're asking you not to run it they'll
go okay you got it you got it no worries
some stories they probably say will run
it anyway but they're they're that's
it's all one big club man and you ain't
in it same Club they used to beach over
the head with George Carlin the France
thing is interesting because uh they
won't they're threatening to shut down
servers from Rumble they've been funding
Ukraine you said but now they're also
taking research and development from
Russia yeah Russia is sending them new
fists I don't know if it's fissile
material but they're sending them Fusion
parts for their Fusion reactor Russia
and France are working together right
now on building a fusion reactor I don't
understand then why they would want to
shut off Russia today it's just very
strange thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to to check out so again
go to timcast.com or tune in Monday
through Friday at 8pm and we'll see you
all there